well we're down inside the living
quarters the sleeping quarters here
right up on the ukrainian front line uh
a few moments ago there were some loud
impacts outside and so um we've come
down into this bunker area and it's
we're waiting for the all clear and it
gives us a chance to to show you around
i mean it is really really tight
quarters in here you can see
their body armor here their weapons as
well the soldiers here some of them have
been living here for a year or so and
that's a reminder that although this
latest offensive by the russians began
back on uh at the end of february this
is a long long war the uh commander the
platoon commander that we've been
speaking to here has been fighting since
2014 in this area now the the so-called
battle of donbass has now begun um that
was uh announced by president zielinski
up in kiev he believes the russian
assault this new chapter in the war has
begun and i think that what we will see
and certainly what the commanders are
telling us here
is that over the course of the next few
days we will see an attempt by the
russians both with their artillery from
behind and their tanks further forward
to push
as far forward as they can and join the
dots there are plenty of individual
villages along this front line ukrainian
villages many of the civilians have gone
but the ukrainian military is dug in the
russians will try and join those dots to
push west but they are it's quite clear
going to meet a very fierce ukrainian
resistance
[Music]
[Music]
almost 90 of the city's housing
infrastructure has been destroyed or has
been damaged 60 percent received a
direct hit from artillery or air strikes
40 percent of residential buildings
cannot be repaired because they have
been destroyed
[Music]
on the 24th of february
our
kid life stopped
[Music]
i remember
the four o'clock
my
elder one
come into our room
and told me mommy mommy i am so
frightened
there is
some horrible sounds around
[Music]
first time we thought
okay day two
okay week two
but now
everybody tells that
six eight months
maybe one two years
i
i am not ready for such long time
nobody
could be ready for it